enfin bien sûr pierre mauroy va devoir
mettre la dernière main ou la
préparation de son équipe
gouvernementale
autrement dit la lumière risque de
briller très tard ce soir à matignon il
y a encore beaucoup de pain sur la
planche pour ce premier ministre qui
n'est nommé que depuis 5 heures
depuis que raymond barre lui a passé les
pouvoirs patrick de carolis
hôtel matignon il est 16 heures 5 heures
après sa nomination pierre mauroy arrive
dans la cour d'honneur pour prendre
officiellement ses fonctions
il est le huitième premier ministre de
la vème république
bré garde républicaine rend les honneurs
pierre mauroy salue les journalistes
anne huissier l'accueil sur le perron
pour le conduire immédiatement au pied
de l'escalier monumental où l'attend
raymond barre
le tête à tête symbole de la passation
des pouvoirs dure 20 minutes
pierre mauroy raccompagne alors son
prédécesseur une dernière poignée de
main raymond barre quitte ainsi la rue
de varenne après avoir exercé les
fonctions de premier ministre pendant
près de 4 ans et 9 mois
dans la cour le personnel applaudit
celui que valéry giscard d'estaing a
appelé le joueur pour de l'économie
il est 16 heures 20 pierre mauroy a pris
possession de sa charge une prononce sa
première déclaration le gouvernement de
la république sera celui de la rigueur
et de l'imagination
en ces temps difficiles rien ne nous
sera donnée sans effort
rien ne se fera sans la durée rien ne
sera possible si la justice sociale ne
vient pas légitime et l'effort demandé à
tous si l'état devenu un partenaire et
non plus un mètre ne rompt pas aux
français de métropole et d'outre-mer
tous leurs droits de citoyens dans le
monde tel qu'il va
la france ne sera une nation libre
force est respectée que si son peuple
est uni dans la france d'aujourd'hui
l'unité n'est possible et légitime que
dans la justice et dans le dialogue avec
l'appui et la confiance du président de
la république avec le concours des
hommes et des femmes de talent et de
courage
ils seront demain avec moi au
gouvernement
nous construirons le changement avec les
français et pour les français
le nouveau gouvernement appelle les
français à bâtir ensemble une nouvelle
citoyenneté citoyenneté d'initiative et
de responsabilité
il sera ainsi fidèle à l'espérance 10
mai et à la vocation de la france
tel est donc le point ni le ps
hôtel matignon il est 16 heures 5 heures
après sa nomination pierre mauroy arrive
dans la cour d'honneur pour prendre
officiellement ses fonctions
il est le huitième premier ministre de
la vème république la garde républicaine
rend les honneurs pierre mauroy salue
les journalistes anne huissier l'accueil
sur le perron pour le conduire
immédiatement au pied de l'escalier
monumental où l'attend raymond barre le
tête à tête symbole de la passation des
pouvoirs dure 20 minutes
pierre mauroy raccompagne alors son père
et ses soeurs une dernière poignée de
main raymond barre quitte ainsi la rue
de varenne après avoir exercé les
fonctions de premier ministre pendant
près de 4 ans et 9 mois
dans la cour le personnel applaudit
celui que valéry giscard d'estaing a
appelé le joffre de l'économie
il est 16 heures 20 pierre mauroy a pris
possession de sa charge
il prononce sa première déclaration le
gouvernement de la république sera celui
de la rigueur et de l'imagination
en ces temps difficiles rien ne nous
sera donnée sans effort rien ne se fera
sans la durée rien ne sera possible si
la justice sociale ne vient pas légitime
et l'effort demandé à tous si l'état
devenu un partenaire et non plus un
mètre ne rompt pas aux français de
métropole et d'outre-mer tous leurs
droits de citoyens dans le monde tel
qu'il va
la france ne sera une nation libre
force est respectée que si son peuple
est uni dans la france d'aujourd'hui
l'unité n'est possible et légitime que
dans la justice et dans le dialogue avec
l'appui et la confiance du président de
la république avec le concours des
hommes et des femmes de talent et de
courage
ils seront demain avec moi au
gouvernement
nous construirons le changement avec les
français et pour les français
le nouveau gouvernement appelle les
français à bâtir ensemble une nouvelle
citoyenneté citoyenneté d'initiative et
de responsabilité
il sera ainsi fidèle à l'espérance 10
mai et à la vocation de la france
elle est donc